hello everyone and welcome to another uh
really exciting game from the official
random World Championship 2022 and
finally we see in action the world the
reigning world official random Champion
Wesley so uh versus uh Icelandic
icelandicone uhstein greterson who was
invited by by the Iceland Chess
Federation as they are the organizers
and he is the highest rated uh player
from Iceland and uh this is the second
game in the first game uh with the white
pieces uh hirover held Wesley to a draw
that they played 100 moves and it was
quite the game this game however is much
much different from that one so let's
dive straight into it and see uh what's
what so Wesley has the white pieces and
he opens with Pawn to D4 and also uh
something that I'm sure you guys would
would appreciate that the first move uh
to this game was made by a very certain
individual uh here you have it let me
just load that up let me make it a
little smaller uh we've discussed him
but a long long time ago uh when we were
doing the Bobby Fischer Saga so there
you have it the first move uh of the of
the event Was Made uh by none other than
uh
torrents on former chairman of the
Icelandic Chess Federation and organizer
or the Fisher sparsky match in 1972 as
they say without him it would not be
possible a very nice photo by David Lada
so there we have it for you guys to
enjoy before we actually check out the
game now let's dive straight into it D4
by Wesley and now Pawn to D5 so both of
them now are sticking to what what seems
to be working best uh like we've seen
that Magnus game against um uh Vladimir
uh that that didn't go all that well but
okay d4d5 Knight to C3 and now Pawn to
C6 we have Ponte E4 by whistling sort of
a a Karo Khan defense if you will we
have the characters and if you could
also just play E6 you don't have to
capture but he prefers an open game the
captures Knight captures and the bishop
the B6 now putting pressure on the D4
Pawn we have C3 and now Knight to D7 we
have Queen to E2 and United D7 even
though it's only move 5 is already a
move that or should be categorized as a
mistake it kind of gives the white
already a winning advantage and it
doesn't seem like it should be so but
after Wesley's Queen to E2 move now you
see that it's a very very hard for black
to actually move his pieces to give you
an example okay uh it's not like Black's
gonna do something like Bishop to d8 but
let's say you have something at the edge
this is already Checkmate so you have to
be very very careful on how you play
this also you have to be careful to have
control over the F6 Square so you don't
want to see something like Knight to F6
so here Bishop back to C7 now regaining
control over the D6 square and now uh
Wesley Castle's King side with knights
to have a knight to F6 charging the
Knight on e4 and just Knight H to G3 we
have Pawn to H5 now getting ready to
kick away the Knight but Wesley just
trades Knight captures and F6 G captures
and now Knight captures on H5 he grabs
the pawn and threatens Knight captures
on F6 with check which will be
devastating
so King 38 by however this is in fact
the the absolute best move recommended
by the engine uh you get the king away
from that e file so now Knight captures
an F6 is not a threat and now Wesley
goes with the bishop to F4 you could
also just bust open the position with D5
but as the world world Fisher random
champion of course Wesley knows that you
must also develop your pieces uh we have
knighted the G6 now attacking the the
bishop here and captures on C7 we have
King captures and now Queen E3 uh trying
to win back um control over that's
another weird Arrow a win a back control
over the dark Square so we don't want
your your opponents to be able to hide
his King if he can develop the bishop
get the Rook entire game and hide the
king let's say all the way on A8 then
black should be fine so here Bishop to
E6 this is what her will try of course
and now how can Wesley continue this
there are two ways both of them require
you to go after the bishop on E6 one of
them is Knight to F4 this is not what
Wesley chose and good thing he didn't
because we wouldn't have this brilliancy
on our hands but just to show you uh
it's a very fine move for example it's
Knight captures Queen captures with
check King D7 now you are
again keeping the king in the center of
the board you are preventing The Rook
from entering the game now let the
bishop to F3 and it's very hard for
black to make a move if he wants the
castle artificially by force Rook V8 and
King the C8 it's not gonna be something
that black enjoys for example Rook after
D1 King the C8 now I just play C4 and
you are busting open the position
there's no playing this if you if you
capture here still just D5 and the
position opens up uh this is completely
unplayable so instead after Bishop T6
okay Wesley could go Knight F4 he goes
Bishop to B3 now says okay I'm still
gonna capture on E6 this is the idea and
if you capture I get the open a file for
my Rook or rather the semi-open a file
and okay Bishop captures and B3 is
played with a capture some B3 and now
Rook to h8 going after the Rook here the
Knight here now comes Queen to G3 with
check and King the D7 is Black's Last
Hope at playing this but he goes for
King to B6 that's uh kind of the idea of
all of this maybe the king can now hide
on the queen side with the move some
like Pony six King day seven and then
the Rook is brought into the game but
here Wesley just plays Pawn to C4 and
you have to uh well you have to be a
strong player to see this and Wesley as
the world champion of this fine format
um definitely as you can see that the
queen controls C7 Pawn control C5 Rook
controls A5 A6 and not a lot of squares
for that black king so of course Pawn to
C4 tightening the news even further A6
freeing up the A7 Square for the black
king now comes Pawn to C5 with check
look at this King to A7 and now what do
you play I'm sure you guys know but just
in case you don't feel free to pause the
video and to win the game for Wesley
it's in fact a forced Checkmate in four
uh so while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding a true
brilliancy in the position and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course Rook captures on A6 we
are going to do it in in very slow
motion there you have it real characters
on A6 so congratulations to everyone who
found this uh and it was in this
position on move 19 that uh hirov
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh truly a
brilliancy by by Wesley with the white
pieces only 19 moves and here we
resigned if if if the pawn captures Rook
then Queen to C7 is mating one but if
the king captures it doesn't really help
you just Rook the A1 check King has to
go to B5 now comes Queen to D3 checking
before and queen to C4 will be Checkmate
so truly truly wonderful interesting
after A6 is played it's already a mate
in five after C5 check this is
absolutely all Force King the B5 runs
into the other Checkmate so you have to
play this and then just a beautiful Rook
after sunny6 beautiful beautiful way to
to to end the game so uh getterson uh
manages the the hold on to a draw
against Wesley in in the first game uh
took him 100 moves but he was able to do
it but in the second one uh he already
played uh played quite a weakening in
the position uh already on move a five
with this Knight to D7 move and after
Queen to E2 there was just no way to
actually get back into the game and
that's all Wesley needed to take control
of the uh of the game so there you see
what a a official random world champion
is capable of uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it here we can
enjoy this photo now one more time if
you guys liked it so there you have it
there's the photo
and nicely nicely presented by David
Lada hope we see many more of those uh
and yeah very nicely done by Wesley
we'll see what happens uh will will he
be able to defend his title or will he
uh will will he not uh so yeah uh that's
the game really hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Derek Alex Williams
Stephen Pryor Alejandra subramanian John
sheriff in the cave halimadi uh
aliyamadi and sharing the the treats for
Meadow thank you very much for that uh
really appreciate it uh so yeah as usual
you can check to all my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
this fine event until it finishes uh
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
hopefully see many more uh epic games
like this one see you soon